that's right the infinity war trailer is
finally here I love his arms in the
trail great thing that's where we
finally have a trailer for us common
folk for infinity war the people who
were in Hall H at Comic Con saw trailer
for months they've been like huh I saw
it you didn't see but now we get to go
up to their level or they get to come
down our level bonus let's talk about it
I love how this trailer starts out where
it's ultimately the Nick Fury monologue
about there was a plan to get a bunch of
extraordinary people together slinking
5-2 fights we couldn't yeah it's a hard
paraphrase whatever it's it's early for
me I literally woke up I was like so
what happened today now here we are
talking about it was sleepy eyes but
everyone has their certain lines from
that monologue we see Bruce Banner so
apparently in Thor Ragnarok when Bruce
Banner was like if the Hulk comes back I
don't think I'm ever coming back no
guess not cuz he's back which kind of
makes the point he made in Thor Ragnarok
pretty pointless unless it was a case of
he's never coming back but Doctor
Strange can do anything
I feel like Doctor Strange is gonna be
there out for a lot of things like
vision has an infinity stone in his
forehead that is gonna rip it out he's
gonna die unless Doctor Strange can
bring him back to life I hope they don't
go that route for something like this I
feel I want to feel like characters can
die spider-man has a suit the one that
he said now Tony Stark I don't want it I
just want to be a kid but when you're on
the bus and you get goosebumps that can
mean only one thing science all right I
guess I'll take that spider suit you see
Santos stroll up and his wife beat her
like what are you doing there boy get
your ass over here you clean up your
room that's a great reveal to his spear
comes out someone a shadowy figure he
grabs a spear and black panther was like
get this man a shield what man boom big
boss baby I don't know if he's big boss
or of Thor at the end his big boss you
take your basic white guy badass and put
a beard on him I'm probably gonna see
big boss from Metal Gear Solid forever
but do you think it's funny that Marvel
Studios was like okay Thor Ragnarok came
out almost a month ago we're gonna
assume you saw it
here's Thor with an eyepatch I do think
the end of this trailer Minh Thor's like
who the hell oh you people it shows the
guardians of the galaxy I feel like that
would have been a better post-credit
scene than what thor ragnarok actually
gave us you don't have to have the
post-credits scene take place right
after the movie you look at the one with
Bucky for a civil war I believe that
post-credit scene was in ant-man took
place halfway through Civil War so
obviously you can do that I just feel
like that would have been
really great post credit scene for thor
ragnarok i mean if that was on the table
essentially they were like we don't want
to do that we really want that as the
post credit scene for the trailer Loki
has the tesseract which means he did get
the tesseract and thor ragnarok again
with them you know like I came out a
month ago dude I feel like he's gonna be
like Boromir he's gonna have the
tesseract like no we need to use this to
fight that no it's gonna totally blow up
in his face down it's gonna be like
crack all right thank you all right but
the really exciting thing in this
trailer is seeing everybody in it and
then how are we gonna end this trailer
you know exactly how they may take our
lives but they'll never take afraid of
[Music]
it's kind of wild to see everything
happening after black panther before we
see black panther it's like alright I
know you don't die there's ever a moment
of tension words like you might die we
know didn't know not gonna die in black
panther that is a dick line that fan
oohs throws out where he's like learn
isn't something one considers when
balancing the universe what this does
put a smile on my face basically guys
when abusive stepdad in a tank top puts
that loop ride from your local State
Fair in the middle of your city troubles
come and got to assemble I thought this
trailer was good it just showed
characters and a lot of punching
happening but the concept that everybody
is coming together to fight the biggest
bad that we've known about since the end
of the original Avengers that's good
stuff that's what I had to do this what
it gave us all right guys so The
Avengers infinity war trailer have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]